it's finally over or is it oh yeah it's
it's definitely over right oh is it
though yeah that's pretty much how i and
probably you as well felt about the
conclusion to the raid on onigashima
that we've gotten with chapter 1050 so
is this the end of the battle of wano
altogether and what will happen next
while leaving a lot of these questions
open we did get a couple of really
important answers in this chapter as
well here's a quick recap in case you've
already forgotten after luffy's dramatic
final attack with an island-sized fist
that blasted kaido into the grounds we
get to see how crazily powerful this
punch of luffy's gear fifth truly was
because it turns out that it carried
such incredible force that it managed to
drill kaido not only into the grounds
but through the crust of the earth into
a magma cave that is revealed to be
located directly beneath wano not only
that but it turns out that big mom has
had the very same fate after laws and
kids final attacks as well which let's
be real here for a moment is pretty wild
even for one piece but i guess it goes
to show just how powerful luffy and co
have become throughout wano turns out
the thing that big mom saw underneath
onygashima wasn't a room full of pony
glyphs and rare devil fruits but one
full of molten flaming hot rock okay so
kaido and big mom seem to be literally
sinking into this pool of magma i think
it's magma because lava would be when it
actually comes out into the open anyways
the fact that oda basically has thrown
these two yonko into literal hell is
pretty extreme i think and not at all
what i personally would have expected
the implication here seems pretty clear
as well these two people are just gonna
be painfully dissolved in an instant
never to be seen again and to top this
all off the two cracks the yonkos made
into that crust cause an underwater
eruption of the volcano that used to be
onigashima if i get that correctly as if
to say yes this is the end of the
emperor kaido and big mom and this
message is driven home even harder when
the narrator corrects his initial
mistake of declaring kite of the victor
the actual victor turns out is luffy on
top of that kaido also finally has
closure in the last chapter realizing
that luffy is indeed joy boy bringing
closure to his big goal of finding
someone strong enough to defeat him
straw hats and the rest of the alliance
are celebrating choppers towards
treating patients good for him including
my man zorro who does seem to be in a
truly dangerous condition right here and
yamato gets the remaining beast pirates
to surrender while momo carries the
whole delegation of the scabbards and
hiori to the flower capital declaring
kaido's defeat and announcing the new
shogun of wano oh also a major shout out
to my man frankie who is the only straw
hat that really looks like he could
still keep easily going after this
respect and so really this entire
chapter is screaming that this fight is
over and the yonko are dead i suppose
and so now the big question here is of
course is that actually true or is oda
sensei throwing us one of his infamous
red herrings here let's think about this
for a second right okay so does it make
actually sense for kaido and big mom two
characters in dire need for some
redemption and closure to die burning to
death painfully in a volcano kaido who
wants nothing more than see joyboy and
die an honorable death and big mom who
has no idea yet that she has been
terrorizing her own people in her
feeding frenzies i do find that kind of
hard to believe i also want to say i
find it a bit suspicious that it wasn't
mount fuji the main volcano of the
island that erupted but onigashima like
a weird angle and the narrator who
wasn't super reliable throughout the
raid either hasn't declared either of
them dead also kaido has a literal file
form as we now know so there's that as
well what i'm getting at here is of
course that i strongly believe that we
will see both kaido and big mom emerge
from this magma pit possibly through
mount fuji well maybe strongly believe
is a bit too much i just really hope to
see this however and i think that's
really important to stress not because i
think that kaido will activate his super
ultra awakening and attack luffy once
again i really think that the fight
between the alliance and the yonko is
over luffy has been recognized by kaido
as joy boy and strong enough and most
importantly it doesn't really look like
luffy will be able to do any fighting
whatsoever for quite some time after
this and so what i much rather would see
or expect to see is a cathartic ending
for kaido's arc i'm pretty sure i have
mentioned that before in my character
analysis on kaido but i really feel like
the best ending for him would be
defending an incapacitated luffy against
some external force like the marines or
blackbeard but honestly no matter if
kaido does come back or not i personally
think that this was by far the most epic
and awesome battle we have witnessed in
the entire story so far i mean really we
saw luffy and kaido grow and change over
many many chapters kaido has literally
been fighting non-stop for over 70
chapters now he has been facing off
against the scabbards against the
supernova against yamato against luffy
again against luffy he has shown why he
is the strongest creature on the planet
giving us both a broad variety of
fantastic attacks and fighting skills
but even more importantly i think a
crazy and thorough character art
throughout the fight that taught us more
and more about his motives and character
making his ultimate defeat against
luffy's final punch feel truly cathartic
it forced luffy to surpass his limits
and himself over and over again to
actually earn the title of emperor that
he got before the ark as did every other
straw hat along the way i think and yes
i know that battles and characters are a
very subjective matter when it comes to
liking it or not liking it but to me
personally kaido is my favorite villain
in the story at the moment and i just
really hope he sticks around a little
bit longer i do want to see a bit more
of him really so far this has been by
far the longest arc and battle in the
history of one piece and especially when
reading it back to back without all the
weekly discussions and expectations that
we all have been building up i find it
to be one piece at its best and i think
this point is driven home really well by
tama and tengoyam who are heavily
featured in this chapter as well we are
being reminded of yasu and his sacrifice
all the events to even the way for the
rage to happen in the first place and
all the people who are putting their
hopes and dreams into luffy to free one
this chapter also set up a lot of things
for the future i think let me start with
zorro and luffy both of them are
completely out after pushing themselves
to the absolute limits and while i think
that luffy will have to be awake for the
final big banquet that surely will have
to happen at the end of wano i'm not
sure if zara will be waking up anytime
soon the way it looks like right now as
i've speculated in my elbaf preview
video i think there is a really good
chance that the two strongest straw hats
might be out for the first part of the
next arc giving room for the rest of the
crew to shine and grow more and catch up
a little bit i'm actually really curious
to find out how taxing gear 5 will
actually be for luffy and how hard or
easy it will be for him to go back into
that form if i had to bet money on it i
suspect it might not be the case that
luffy can now just use this form
whenever but has to properly master it
first and of course i also really can't
wait for an update to the straw hats
bounties that surely has to happen soon
as well that news bird with the new
bounty posters is always a major
highlight of every single arc for me in
fact i do have a bounty myself sort of
58 million berries for the 580 000
awesome people of you that are
subscribed to this channel i'm very far
from reaching luffy's level or any of
the straw hats really but i am
determined to at least come for treble's
head who has 99 million so please help
me with that by subscribing yamato is
another big factor in this chapter for
me in case you've been around that long
you know that i've wanted yamato to
become a straw hat ever since their
introduction honestly i would be
seriously hurt if it didn't happen after
all of the hints that we've been getting
so far and in this chapter in particular
the beast pirates even acknowledge her
as part of the alliance yamato is the
one who actually catches luffy and who
continued his fight with kaido until he
got back on his feet and so i really
expect that we will get an answer to
that question as well very very soon
then there is of course also the
cliffhanger with dengero who proclaims
the next proclaims who proclaims the
next shogun of wano so will it be momo
or will it be hiyori if it is hiori then
momo will surely keep sailing with the
straw hats 100
and given that he has kaido's powers and
is now at least physically grown up i
would have no issue with that at all and
i'll even give him that he has grown up
personality wise now as well he has
become a true leader made hard decisions
for himself showed real courage and
saved his people from destruction and so
if he became the new shogun that would
of course also be ironic because wana
would get another dragon ruler but this
time at least a good one other than that
i think it's really crazy to think that
despite all the celebration and seeming
end to the fight i still find it very
hard to believe somehow that wanna will
be wrapping up anytime soon there are
still so many loose ends the
government's waiting outside the border
questions to be answered i don't know
i'd like to think that there is at least
an act number four waiting for us here
and if you want to get a full analysis
and all my thoughts on luffy's battle
with kaido you really shouldn't skip
this video right here